hey guys hey hey
[Music]
sorry didn't mean to interrupt not at
all i'm gonna head back to siberia there
oh
ciao i started dating aaron this summer
it has been in a word
exquisite
gabe is awesome
he's accomplished so much
career-wise and height-wise
thank god he's my boss because i would
not have said yes to a first date if i
didn't have to but
it's been great and what do we have here
from my secret admirer that's you caught
i dominate valentine's day i practically
make romance into a science
roses are red violets or blue look in
the vase to find your first clue
oh my gosh it's a romantic scavenger
hunt oh close it's a romantic treasure
hunt a scavenger hunt is where you find
items from a master list
this is where you follow clues that lead
to a prize common misuse good luck but
there's no clue i'll get to work
i can't cause there's no clue the puzzle
is the clue
i picked out our movie it's called
suspiria it pushes all the boundaries
all your preconceived notions about what
horror can be come crashing down when i
win
we're gonna watch wall-e
where all the boundaries of
color are pushed it is hard to explain
why erin is doing so well today the only
thing i can think is aaron is living out
some slumdog millionaire scenario where
every word she's playing has a
connection to her orphan past
it's possible
so i won i know you get to pick
well that's actually what i came to talk
to you about i know how much you want to
watch wall-e yes so
i got us a compromise this movie's
called hardware it tells the story of a
killer combat robot just like wally that
the government invented to destroy
humans it's some of what you like and
some of what i like
and
marry that sorry we're late gabe fell in
the shower such a klutz and it took the
fire department forever to get there
look who i found yeah well i was very
hard to find let's go ahead and wash
your hands
is this the same
dough that you use for the pizza crust
yeah waste not right so these are pizza
dogs these aren't pigs in a blanket per
se
michael knows everything there is to
know about snacks well
gabe was born in 1982. he was the
longest baby in the hospital he's the
longest baby in this room what's the
longest thing you've ever seen
for me it was the tale from a jet erin
you don't have to yeah you know what
erin you do after michael
you were making this harder than it has
to be that's what she said
and aaron hannon
come on up here to receive your cutest
redhead in the office awards
thank you thank you
thank you
this is the first award i've ever won in
my entire life
people were right about the dundies
they are magical
but
i don't feel it
and i think that's because i'm not with
the right person
gabe
what
we should break up
what
i'm not attracted to you
i just i cringe when you talk
i have to be honest
right right pam
thank you for hearing me
okay well this is embarrassing um
obviously really angry at aaron here
comes that quarter life crisis
everyone's talking about
all right i'm gonna go
let's
there you go
damn i was cold
two o'clock should probably be okay i
can either take your number or
i'm sorry this can't wait he's just
gonna call back erin i'm in love with
you
i don't believe in much okay i don't
believe in horoscopes i don't believe in
christmas uh uh i sure as hell don't
believe in god
um
or maybe there's a god i don't i don't
know i mean it's just not a guy with a
long white beard
or it could be i mean it's possible that
that is exactly what what god is
but for for all of the disbelief
i believe in us
i believe in love
you have made me believe that for all of
the hokum out there
uh do we not have voicemail
dwight doesn't trust robots to give us
our messages
well
it's just
it messes up my rhythm
i'm taking a break from dating
gabe was a great guy with so many
wonderful qualities but it was a
challenge being touched by him
gabe
sweet aaron i'm throwing the halloween
party and i just want to amp it up a
little i think it could use some
extra pizzazz okay where'd escape factor
in remember that halloween party you
took me to once the one where i i
started crying as soon as i walked in
and
i didn't stop crying yes
lars into kakos okay well let's say that
i wanted this party to be a tiny
tiny bit like that one
just
more adult more more scary and sexy i
will make this sexier than you could
ever imagine it was just scary if we
wanted ideas for scary stuff
[Applause]
oh that'd be scary what are you thinking
all right let me go get it
i need to talk to you you can't be in
here this is a lady's banner aaron aaron
i respect your privacy but i will follow
you in here every time you go if that's
what it takes
agreed
not cool man
i really think you should leave someday
you are going to tell our grandchildren
about how their grandfather won you back
in a women's room can we talk about this
later i have to go okay just read the
letter under your windshield wiper okay
it explains everything okay okay
see one gabe well
thank you all for coming in just wanted
to check in how was everyone's day
honestly it was a little weird
really
hmm that's interesting because aaron and
pete
thought it wouldn't be weird at all
why do you think it was weird gabe maybe
because you and aaron used to be an item
i still wear aaron's button dance around
the condo sometimes so it feels to me
like we're still in a relationship a lot
and alice uh i understand you once
dumped pete ouch it was an amicable
breakup andy
okay while we're rewriting history you
never had a drinking problem it was
college that is what you do
yeah you're also supposed to go to
classes so there's that hey andy is this
at all work-related we'll get to that
gabe did aaron ever tell you that she
loves you
no no no no no no no no no no
she wouldn't even let me say it it was
adorable she'd plug her ears and scream
her heart out can you stop talking
because every word out of your mouth is
like the squawk of an ugly pelican
i got a tattoo for you
i didn't ask you to get that nike swoosh
nobody did you did that for you just do
it
you were the hit that i was just doing
so you're dating a secretary now moving
up in the world pete
she's nice to me
how's that pe degree coming that's what
he wanted to be his dream in college was
to be a gym teacher well guess what he
could still be a gym teacher in fact we
could all still be gym teachers so i
technically cannot i don't have the lung
capacity to blow a whistle oh my
god oh
what kind of music are you into peter
uh
i like all kinds of music gabe really
all kinds she likes songs of hate
written by the white knights of the ku
klux klan are you even hearing this he
didn't even say this he's not a very
sophisticated man i mean he can't use
chopsticks so do i need to say anything
else
aaron
i've been to japan i know how to use
chopsticks so well
come back
the chopsticks is not the measure of the
mass i am
you